they said the age of heroes who never
come again that's too
[Applause]
what are your superpowers again I'm rich
[Music]
shall we
if you guys missed it last night Geoff
Johns Loki dropped a huge teaser for
something that's happening later this
year in conjunction with the Justice
League movie as well as something that's
happening in the comics right now with
Flash Batman the button crossover in
them bringing The Watchmen into the DC
Universe there's a lot of stuff going on
I'll explain how it all works and how
it's fitting together between the movies
in the comic books so there's a new
round of the Blash winged giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video but I will tell you right now that
this is the single most important thing
that's happening with exception to the
Marvel movies not to take away from any
of the Star Wars stuff that's happening
later in the year but there's so much
seismic stuff that Geoff Johns is
working on behind the scenes then this
is all coming together in November and
it's all obviously timed with the
release of the Justice League movie so
it's all based on what's happening with
the Superman character in how he's
bringing hope back into the DC Universe
while that's also happening with the
Superman character in the Justice League
movie the comic book side of the
equation is a little more complicated so
I'll explain the buttons stuff that's
going on and what that has to do with
Watchmen why Superman is so important
and then how that ties in with what's
going on in the movies as this teaser
poster implies there's like the doomsday
logo from the doomsday event in the
comics where Superman killed it's a
countdown clock the Doomsday Clock and
it's going to be Superman versus dr.
Manhattan and they're meant to be this
juxtaposition of how Superman represents
the best of humanity even though he's an
alien in dr. Manhattan who's completely
out of touch with humanity even though
he himself used to be a human of Earth
the big twist of DC rebirth is that they
used it to fix a lot of continuity
problems that they had with the new 52
the new 52 comics basically rewrote
everyone's backstories sales started
tanking creative wasn't great there were
a couple good stories to come out of it
but DC basically came up with rebirth is
a way to make their comics great again
make DC great again and it totally
worked
they brought hope back into the DC
Universe which is what Geoff Johns said
he felt like was missing but as part of
the arc they used it as a way to bring
the
Watchmen characters in two main DC
continuity and as a way to explain how
that was all going to work he teased the
idea that dr. Manhattan was the reason
for all the bad things that had happened
during the new 52 period dr. Manhattan
just completely messing with humanity
so in this big flash Batman button
crossover they're slowly teasing the
reveal of dr. Manhattan at the end of
the latest Batman issue reverse-flash is
racing with the button going towards the
main antagonist they haven't officially
revealed it yet but they're being pretty
clear and on the nose that it's going to
be dr. Manhattan when they get to
wherever it is that they're going to so
for some reason dr. Manhattan is being a
total [ __ ] to the entire DC Universe
and Superman is going to face off with
him when the Doomsday Clock hits
midnight I know the idea doomsday makes
it sound like they're gonna kill
Superman but I don't think that's going
to happen so what they're gonna do is
have this big event in November time
with the release of the Justice League
movie Superman is is basically going to
beat out dr. Manhattan I am very
optimistic about it I do feel like
Superman is going to help remind dr.
Manhattan of his humanity bring hope
back into the DC universe in a standing
way because right now there's all these
good things that are happening but you
have the villain dr. Manhattan that
keeps trying to roll back all the good
things that are happening part of the
reason for releasing it at the end of
the year with the Justice League movie
is obviously because the same thing is
happening with the Superman character in
the DC EU in that he is bringing hope
back into the universe so the Justice
League movie plot is a little bit
different from what's going on with the
Superman versus dr. Manhattan storyline
obviously the Watchmen characters are
not in the Justice League movie but
what's happening is is that are using
Superman in the comics to bring hope
back into DC Comics and they're using
Superman in the movies to bring hope
back into the DC EU there was this big
backlash last year about how some of the
DC movies just felt completely joyless
in you know Superman did not feel like
the Superman bringing hope the way he
should so you have this big comic book
event you have Superman in Justice
League that is fixing that you can tell
by the way they're marketing Justice
League right now that they're keeping
their Superman cards very close to the
vest just because they don't want to
give away in either big
twist of the movie but they're being
very open about metaphorically what's
happening with the character in how
they're using the comics to strengthen
that idea so they've been a lot of
rumors about what's actually going on
with the Superman character there's
actually a really bad rumor I totally
don't believe it but it's fascinating
that Superman is actually going to be
like emceed and will be bad for a
portion of the film and the Justice
League will actually have to fight him
before he turns back good I don't
believe that's what's going to happen
but it is absolutely fascinating to hear
all the Justice League rumors it's just
the reason why Superman isn't in and all
the marketing why he isn't there at the
beginning is they explain that they want
to make it difficult for the Justice
League to come together and there'd be
almost no movie if Superman like the God
on earth that they call him during the
other DC EU movies went around and said
look there's a big problem coming I need
you to come with me people are much more
willing to believe Superman and take him
at face value then they would believe
someone like Bruce Wayne Batman just
look at the way Aquaman reacts to him
you know rich guy from Gotham City what
do you care about me why should I listen
to you I have enough problems of my own
he has all this crap that's going on at
Atlantis there's all this stuff going on
in the Aquaman movie that's going to
sort of overlap with the Justice League
movie there'll be a lot of prequel
elements in the Aquaman movie but
there'll be a lot of stuff happening
after just because the movie itself is
being released after the Justice League
movie but the same thing is true for all
the other Justice League characters they
have their own problems to deal with the
flash is one of the few people along
with Wonder Woman that are like okay
totally on board from day one
Wonder Woman looks like she has some
reservations though I love the way she
looks at Bruce Wayne like she's totally
down to help but she's been used by all
the trappings of Batman all the tools
the paraphernalia the costumes even
Aquaman is like he dressed like a bat I
totally dig it so it's not like it's all
gonna be on Superman to bring hope back
into justice leavin though that's the
way he's being used it's just that we've
only gotten that one trailer so you
haven't gotten a full sense for how they
use humor in the film but you can see
how they wanted to lighten the tone a
little bit and a lot of the same thing
was happening with the new 52 comics and
that's what DC Bri birth changed about
that it sort of reset the characters a
true base so that they feel like they
should feel so if you felt that way
during the DC movies last year like some
of these characters don't feel like the
way they should feel you know Superman
why is he acting this way why is Batman
acting this way the Justice League movie
is like a large course correction and
Wonder Woman will sort of tee that up
I've already done an early reactions
video most people are largely positive
on it but there's a big embargo so you
won't hear any official reviews for a
little while but if I do get a chance to
see it early I will totally post a
non-spoilery review the trailer footage
doesn't do it justice most of this is
either like low res or the coloring
isn't quite right because it's like a
downloaded version of another download
so don't let this footage fool you the
colors pop is so much brighter is gonna
be so much fun
but you have all this crazy stuff that's
happening at the same time in the comics
too you do not have to read the comics
to understand what's going on in the
movie but if you weren't already
planning on checking this out I would
recommend you check out the buttons
storyline because it's the direct lead
up into this Doomsday Clock Watchmen
Superman Justice League story that'll be
happening in November but it'll be
awhile before this part of it drops and
they'll be doing a much better job of
like thematically linking what's going
on with this story in the Justice League
movie then say like Marvel did when
Captain America Civil War came out and
they did Civil War - that was more of an
example of them just tacking the name
Civil War onto a comic book storyline
that bore no resemblance to what was
happening in the movie but there's a
whole bunch of stuff that just dropped
this is a big week for TV announcements
so we'll learn a lot about what's
happening with all the comic book shows
next week I've already posted that
gifted trailer video for the x-men TV
show there's some stuff happening with
flash arrow legends of tomorrow Black
Lightning all the DC stuff so I'll try
to post as much of that stuff as
possible Seoul say congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Carole green
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details where you wait for that
you can click here to learn what
everybody is saying about the Wonder
Woman movie that's seen it so far and
you can click here for a brand new flash
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you